if you're undecided if you just want to
go for the social experience if you just
want to move away from home if you want
to generally explore the liberal arts I
think that all those things can be done
much more cheaply effectively and again
with building more of an entrepreneurial
spirit by taking a path that's not
traditional college my book is called
better than college how to build a
successful life without a four-year
degree yeah College is a place where
people go for four years in some
institution and college can or cannot
give you a higher education for some it
does for others doesn't to me a higher
education is the capacity to self-direct
your life to deal with rapid change
essentially to be an entrepreneur in the
widest sense of the word in the book
there's lots of paths that somebody
could take I say that there's a five
step process for giving yourself a
higher education without college first
step is to find or build self knowledge
that's where the journey starts and
where it ends so ask yourself the really
serious questions to make sure you're
started in the right direction then when
you have that direction give yourself
assignments and so again this will look
different for different people for some
they might need to get themselves to
India for six months for others they may
need to start a startup or start a
freelance business others they just want
to read a lot or maybe take those free
Ivy League courses that are popping up
everywhere online so after you started
giving yourself assignments then create
and share value with them I think
there's a big difference between just
reading and traveling because you're
interested in doing it for yourself and
then doing it with an eye for how it can
fulfill other people's needs against
entrepreneurial ethic and so if you are
traveling you could blog you could write
travel guide books you could do things
that you know especially using social
media and lots of online tools can
produce value for other people if you
can make a really informed decision
about going into a licensed career if
you want to become doctor lawyer
architect public school teacher or if
you do want to do PhD research science
something that really involves
university scientific research
facilities then you have a good reason
to go to college but if you're undecided
if you just want to go for the social
experience if you just want to move away
from home
if you want to generally explore the
liberal arts I think that all those
things can be done much more cheaply
effectively and again with building more
of an entrepreneurial spirit by taking a
path that's not traditional college for
a long time a liberal arts education has
been inexpensive enough that I didn't
have to worry too much about going to
school getting a four-year degree in the
liberal arts and then if you didn't use
it after graduating it's no big deal
because the price wasn't that big the
debt wasn't that high but now average
college tuition price twenty thousand
dollars a year if you graduate from
college which most people will do in
five years now instead of four you love
twenty five thousand dollars in debt
those costs and the debt levels have
skyrocketed master than health care
faster than consumer price index
I think easy federal student aid is
almost precisely reason why colleges are
able to increase their costs as they
have done over the past decades without
increasing any tangible value or student
performance coming out of it and so I'd
say you're just pushing further down the
rabbit hole if you say we should just
give more easy aid to students
that's not solving the fundamental issue
self-directed learning is not the same
thing as self isolated learning or
structureless learning it means that you
are seeking out and providing your own
support systems and structure instead of
just taking it as a big expensive
package deal from a college and so I can
still give myself structure I can still
have goals and be accountable to someone
as a self-directed learner without
college and is a more challenging path
to take but I believe that there are
resources that support out there for
people who do want to take it say if
you're still teenager you're an early
child just google the term unschooling
and see what you find my favorite books
in the world of unschooling are from the
author john taylor gatto who was a
famous New York City public school
teacher and then he quit wrote an op-ed
to The Wall Street Journal and said I
don't want to teach kids I don't want to
teach anymore because I don't want to
hurt kids I defined unschooling as
full-time self-directed learning so
usually the term was applied in that k12
realm and legally unschoolers are the
same thing as home schoolers so they
fall under that umbrella they're subject
to specific state by state regulation
but when you unschool you are not taking
a formal curriculum and doing it at home
like a lot of people imagine
homeschooling to be it's about helping
your child identify and then pursue
their interests their passions their
curiosities and I believe that's a
philosophy that you can take all the way
up through the college years and if you
do it in a way that produces value for
other people you think like an
entrepreneur then it can self-directed
learning and unschooling can provide an
alternative to a college program